if you've kept up with the recent gaming
landscape it feels like we've seen far
cry 6 again and again at every event so
it's kind of relieving to get my hands
on the game instead of passively
observing and after playing about five
hours let me tell you this sure is a far
cry game a huge open world mission
spread across a wide map explosions and
fire fights camps to clear out weapons
to unlock and upgrade you name it i have
a bit of a been there done that feeling
albeit with some legitimately fun
moments in between how was my day well i
followed a bloodthirsty rooster into
combat after he blew up a truck
it's a variation on a formula from a
gameplay perspective but there are ways
in which it seems to be forming its own
identity that's primarily because of its
setting yara the team behind far cry 6
has been trying to make yara as much of
a character as anton castillo the main
villain played by fame actor giancarlo
esposito the shorthand four yara would
be real life cuba it's a latin american
country composed of islands in the
caribbean west indies in the midst of an
armed revolution its people are being
crushed under the weight of a violent
dictatorship and you see this in
explicit detail in just the opening
hours you playing as a woman or man
named donnie rojas get rolled into a
larger gorilla movement called libertad
donnie gradually buys into this
revolution and the means necessary to
carry it out gameplay-wise this means
seizing checkpoints and territories
gunning down castile's army and cronies
and carrying out missions for various
leaders across yara's islands
narratively it means taking control of
the resources that turn the tides of
conflict and understanding why this
collective effort is worth the struggle
the hesitation with far cry is that
ubisoft games tend to tiptoe around its
thematic backdrops or settle for generic
political tales for set dressing simply
using them as playgrounds for wild open
world action i suppose far cry 6 could
get away with that but drawing
inspiration directly from a real world
revolution only a few generations
removed comes with the expectation of a
somewhat earnest portrayal the narrative
director naveed kavari has said as much
and that this game is embracing its
political themes now five hours with
what's presumably a game that takes
upwards of 50 hours to reasonably
complete isn't going to show you every
facet of its narrative but i will say
that it sets a strong tone from the
start and has moments that show promise
when character dialogue in the main
story isn't leaning into goofiness or
simple platitudes it seems to be
genuinely laying the groundwork for
understanding the intricacies of what
yarans are really fighting for and why
it's important to the larger
revolutionary group a conversation
emblematic of this takes place as you
finish the mission to leave the first
island after sabotaging two of
castillo's warships you take a speedboat
with clara libertad's leader and have a
brief affecting exchange asking what now
what's your plan when you reach america
me and my friend alejo were going to
work [ __ ] jobs until we could scrape up
some money open a body shop if the
yankee blockade taught us anything it's
how to keep things running when you got
nothing that's the dream
sure yankees might pay you to park their
cars or pick their fruit but you'll
never be one of them
the american dream doesn't come in our
color okay
if we're [ __ ] on dreams what are you
going to do if you win president garcia
the next president won't last six months
before they are assassinated wait
what it's the truth won't re-election
solve that what happened to your list
it's a vision danny but i'm not as naive
as you think
this revolution will free yada but won't
fix it when we take the capital yatta
will be burning
could be civil war factions warlords
born-backed coups take your pick yarens
will be killing yarens for a generation
this fight will take the rest of my life
yara is stuck in a cycle of tyranny and
revolution
my job is to show us how to break it
this sets a bold tone but also the
expectation for far cry 6 to follow
through on what's distinctly a latin
american story about revolution it's not
a throwaway conversation in a side quest
or one that's happening in the
background of a mission it paints a
picture of the rebel group you're
fighting for it establishes a basic but
clear understanding that america isn't
always the answer and is often part of
the problem and that liberation is much
more than taking up arms and killing
tyrants although that is primarily what
you're doing as the player so anton
castillo looms over the main story beats
and his violent imposing presence fills
each scene alongside his reluctant 13
year old son diego who still has a moral
compass it creates an uneasy tension
however castile's motivations aren't
really laid out and don't have any
particular depth in the early hours he
has complete control of yara's workforce
and production of a cancer drug called
veviro he enforces this through violence
and oppression and is manipulative by
using his quote love for yara to excuse
everything the hope is that there's more
to his deal than evil for evil's sake if
anything diego seems more intriguing
from a narrative perspective some scenes
aren't for the faint of heart as they
can be quite gruesome but far cry is
also goofy in its open world hijinks the
inherent bombast that comes with the
series doesn't necessarily preclude it
from featuring more poignant moments of
storytelling when done right a dash of
levity can help personify its world and
characters for example the quote legends
who fought yara's previous regime are an
interesting bunch with their ability to
influence the movement and their
tendency to just be washed up old timers
but then there's this oddball farmer who
has a super powered chicken named
chicharron who you chase around in a
series of side quests and it's all
rather annoying and grating and yeah i'm
not a fan of shooting dogs like fish in
a barrel no matter how rabid they may be
on the flip side there's an upbeat but
careless loose cannon hanron whose fiery
edge brings some attitude to the cast
all this is scratching the surface
considering the size of the game but i
found it supporting characters to be hit
or miss in the brief play session so
your mileage may vary what also comes
with the territory of a far cry game is
its wild gameplay shenanigans like
summoning planes and helicopters to drop
into a base and go in guns blazing
before fending off waves of soldiers or
burning down a whole farm that's
producing veviro with a flamethrower to
the tune of a spanish rendition of the
italian revolutionary song bella ciao
i'd say it's better than far cry 3's
infamous level with the skrillex beat
drop companions in combat called amigos
basically function like guns for hire
from the previous game except now
they're animals that await your command
like the gator guapo or the little pup
that could chorizo all the while you
have npcs shouting kong yokong more
times than the kid marrows akas at the
end of a bodega boys episode
so yes far cry 6 does feature that level
of ridiculousness but overall the game
uses its familiar design philosophies of
a typical open world shooter and if
you've played modern entries of far cry
you'll know what to expect solid gunplay
the ability to make stealth and action
and a bunch of conventional and
unconventional weapons to toy with at
work benches you'll craft mods and
upgrades customize your loadouts and
perks and tinker with supremos which are
various super like abilities strapped
onto you like a backpack and it's
imperative you keep up with this since
parts of yara aren't very friendly to
the ill-equipped it's a formula that
seems to still be working for those who
aren't burnt out on these types of games
whether or not the formula can evolve
throughout the game's run time and hold
your interest is always the question
though yara is huge and there's a lot of
open space so we'll see if it makes the
most of it
armed rebellion in a country plunged
into chaos under a ruthless dictator
yeah i can believe a band of gorillas
would pull up guns blazing but i think
far cry 6 is more promising if and when
it gives you a reason to fight a
compelling narrative can help carry you
through the repetition that tends to
creep up the deeper you get into a game
like this of course stories of
revolution are infinitely more complex
and nuanced than what can be packed into
a far cry let alone any video game and
some of us come from countries shaped by
spanish colonization and we've grown up
more aware of our histories of
revolutionary movements so for me it's
at least enticing that far cry 6's story
is trying to be more than a veneer for a
spicy shooting gallery that much i can
appreciate more importantly remember
that people make games if you believe
that basic fact then you owe it to
yourself to at least be informed about
ubisoft's employees taking action for
changes to company culture in response
to hostile work environments abuse and
sexual harassment that's been documented
across ubisoft's various studios open
letters and signatures in solidarity
with the workers of activision blizzard
are also indicative of how ubisoft's
leadership has failed to respond
accordingly how lawsuits and movements
affect the way you engage with ubisoft
games that's your choice but to ignore
it is to deny that the people who make
these games deserve a stable workplace
free of hostility it's the more
important revolution happening in video
games with actual tangible effects on
people's lives and is showing the very
real effect of collective action far cry
6 is only a video game but understand
that taking action to make the world
around you a better place is always the
move
you